well comedian and podcast host Adam
Carolla is one of the most stour
defenders of actual free speech left in
America Kroll is not only a famous host
he's he's an amazing car racing fan and
participant we're just in LA last week
and we decided to go over to his race
car garage and talk to him because we
couldn't resist cuz it's amazing here's
part of the conversation that resulted
Adam Carolla you've been on the road for
the past several months talking about
free speech I know your views on it have
you been able to convince the audience
especially young people that free speech
matters are they on your side do you
think I've been able to convince my
audience who already thought free speech
mattered I think people I think the
pendulum is starting to swing back a
little bit you know we've had hit a
saturation level
I sort of believe as human beings we
work this way like I believe that in
that late 80s there were hair bands and
big guys wearing you know boo fonts and
spandex and Aquanet eyeliner and
everything else and then that gave way
to grunge music yeah Kurt Cobain
tattered shirts nobody cared right so
it's like what could be further away
from hair bands grunge music and that's
what came next so I'm starting to wonder
if it's swinging back I think the
insanity of the woke folks out there
have forced sane people to push back and
we may be going from that hair band to
the grunge movement have the woke people
push back against you you know what
people are they'll push back against
anybody anybody you don't seem bother
you're like the one person I know who
seems totally uninterested in what the
woke people say and totally unbothered
by their attacks well I know what's in
my heart and I hate that statement but I
Know Who I am
you can't convince me I hate a group
hate a sexual proclivity hate a person
you couldn't convince me I hated a
neighbor or friend or Hispanics blacks
gays whatever you can't bestow that upon
me that's something that's inside me and
I
aware of it and I know I don't so you
can't convince me of that so you're not
afraid because you know what they're
saying is the lie yeah and I'm I'm an
atheist like I really don't care like at
the end of the day I want to go race one
of these cars and wrench on something
and build something and eat dinner of my
kids and wife like I I there's a sort of
freedom and in not caring there's a real
freedom and not caring huh why don't
more people feel that way I think
there's a vanity and I and I think that
everybody is is wired to be a little bit
narcissistic and no one wants to go
online and read bad things about
themselves and nobody wants to read
untruths or inaccurate things about
themselves and so we are wired to
alleviate so ii-i've never thought about
it this way but here you go
when your ankle is sore you're wired to
stay off your ankle like less weight yes
hop lean this way you go on Twitter you
read a bunch of horrible things about
yourself you're wired to alleviate
you're not wired to put weight on a
rolled ankle you're wired to go oh
people are saying x y&z about me on
Twitter let's fix that in the fix is
apologizing and walking statements back
but to get it to go away
I want alleviate I'm not interested in
the truth I'm not interested in what the
history books say I want this my ankle
hurts I want to get the weight off it
immediately so you walking this stuff
back you apologizing you cow telling to
these people is a way to get the weight
it's like a crutch and I can get the
right weight off this and it'll go away
and I don't care about what the doctor
or the orthopedic right no pains it
hurts I want it to go away but you don't
play that game and therefore they don't
bother you and it just seems like that's
a model for the rest of us that if
everybody had that attitude like I don't
care I just want to wrench on my course
and have dinner with my kids they won't
have no power they're not in the
business of banging their head against
the wall they're in the business of
mowing you down and moving on to their
next subject you know what I mean there
their their immediate gratification
group let's remember these were kids who
got everything they wanted immediately
well if you don't give them a media
gratification they're off you in like
two days
yeah no this is not you know a long slog
that's gonna take place over months and
years this is you give me what I want
right now which is an apology or to
either get fired from your job or
whatever that is you to be humiliated
and you to be contrite and if you don't
give in almost immediately they
immediately move on to their next then
you'd have to be a [ __ ] to give in
immediately to unreasonable demands
wouldn't you I think so but you know you
think about all the politicians and all
the newscasters and and voices out there
you think about the ones that just sort
of weather the storm and just put their
head down and said no apology they
immediately pack up and go find another
victim or somebody to turn into a victim
and if it's clear that there's nothing
here for you if they wring you like a
bar rag and no tears come out they move
on because they want a bucket of Tears
they want a bucket of your tears and
they ring and they ring and you just go
don't let it drop fall and if the drop
doesn't hit that pail they pick up the
pail and they go let's go find some more
tears perfect perfect thank you